[Music
] citizens however are protagonists
european conserva I put our
European group of conservatives and
reformists in it and a group that some
fundamental values ​​in its constitutive act
in the prague document from the defense
of the family to the free market to
respect for national sovereignty
whoever  sxc members settini the campus
making sek school of the european millstones
the ears stars geishas incomes a nylon
the defense and role of national states
the role of parliament that the relationship with
the territory is fundamental and this is
one of the cornerstones of our group
that we are  euro realists we don't want to
smash anything but at the same time we are
convinced that as things have
gone up to now they are going absolutely
wrong we need to change
this Europe profoundly
[Music]